there was a time maybe seven or eight
years ago where I was going to come back
for a couple spider-man movies after
they had done their first Amazing
Spiderman and I'd had on the very first
vitamin I'd sort of planned out what I
thought the first three movies should be
and then all the assorted personalities
it didn't work for me to keep keep
writing the spider-man movies again
jumped or pushed who knows and so I
can't so I was excited to come back and
try to finish the story I'd started
telling him the first one in and because
we were about to agree that I was gonna
do that I pulled out all the old stuff
and I'd started outlining those two
movies and and I thought boy that's you
can't go home again that moment has
passed the time when I was really
feeling it was ten years ago and there's
no point trying to trying to recreate it
so I did who do you remember where you
were planning for the subsequent reaming
spider-man movies yeah it was it was
basically it was a telling the telling
of the the Gwen Stacy you know Harry
Osborn story but it's based everything
out differently and you know I I I
wanted I wouldn't go in to be killed in
in the middle of the second movie
because that tends you know it's
following sort of the Empire Strikes
Back model and you know I have different
villains I wanted to use just a
different way to tell that story